lunettes casquette frisbee c'est la
vidéo des vacances salut les p'tits
mantallot de la team menthe à l'eau
c'est la dernière vidéo avant mes
vacances quoi
mais qu'est ce qui se passe ils arrêtent
le mental blog je n'arrête pas le mental
blog au contraire avant de vous dire
exactement ce qui va se passer à partir
de demain je vais vous dire ce qui va se
passer à partir de mon retour je vais
prendre le temps de revoir un petit peu
la chaîne de mettre les mains dans le
cambouis comme on dit puisque mon rythme
de publication qui est délicat quotidien
ne permet pas de prendre à ces temps où
assez de recul
donc je revois un petit peu l'habillage
de la chaîne est ce que je fais une
intro ou pas est-ce que je peux pas
produire un petit peu mieux est-ce que
je peux pas écrire un peu différemment
j'ai vraiment envie d'améliorer encore
plus la chaîne vise à vite vous
vis-à-vis de moi aussi en fait pour
notre plaisir à tous si vous n'avez pas
vu la vidéo numéro 100 sur 366 on me
demande des fois pourquoi sur 366 parce
que c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un
an et qui à 366 jours et que j'ai
commencé le 1er janvier donc si vous
avez pas vu la vidéo numéro s'en aller
la voir parce que je fais une annonce
dessus sur le jour on atteindra les 50
mille abonnés le répète comme c'est un
peu plus avenant mais quand on sera 50
mille abonnés sur la chaîne je me
mettrai à organiser un mental peuple et
qu'est ce qu'un mental oeuvre un mental
up c'est un petit peu comme un mythe up
sauf que de manière informelle ce sera
pas forcément sur une scène ou quoi je
vais vous présenter les nouveautés je
suis en train d'écrire pour le nouveau
spectacle c'est à dire que c'est plus
qu'il n'est dit c'est de l'inédit de
l'édit de celle inédit ce sera fait en
mode informel je demanderais aussi vos
avis que vous aimez ce que vous aimez
pas ce qui vous a bluffé ce qui vous a
pas bluffer comme ça vous allez
participer en quelques manières au test
du bêta test du béta bêta test du
nouveau spectacle
donc vous l'aurez compris à cette
chemise ridicule à partir de demain je
pars en vacances en vacances quoi je
pars en vacances
qu'est ce qui va se passer sur la chaîne
pendant les vacances toujours la même
chose une vidéo par jour à 17 heures la
semaine et à 11 heures les samedis et
dimanches sauf qu'on ne va pas suivre le
calendrier habituel de la chaîne d'abord
pendant les quelques prochains jours qui
viennent je vais vous apprendre à
résoudre ceux ci à apprendre à résoudre
ce rubik's cube en moins de deux minutes
et avec seulement cinq formules c'est
les vidéos j'avais préparé au cas où je
sois malade dans la première partie de
l'année et que j'avais décidé de mettre
sinon le jour je voudrais prendre des
vacances c'est le cas ce sont également
les premières vidéos que j'ai filmé au
youtube space à paris j'avais filmé sa
jeu pour ceux qui me suivent sur les
réseaux sociaux et c'est très facile
hein
un remix capcom vous pouvez les derrière
le constater mais vous pouvez aussi
bientôt vous allez faire ça mais après
cette série de vidéos qu'est ce qui va
se passer parce que je serai pas encore
rentré durant tout le mois d'août où
statistiquement c'est le mois où il ya
le moins de personnes actives sur
youtube pour terminer mes vacances et
pour éviter de cramer des sujets
intéressants qu'on pourrait faire en
prenant mieux le temps à la rentrée
j'organise un jeu de l'été le jeux des
énigmes tous les jours pendant presque
un mois parce que j'arrêterais avant fin
août quand même je vous donne une énigme
à résoudre et le lendemain je vous donne
la solution de l'énigme avec une
nouvelle énigme
j'espère que cette idée vous plaira j'ai
déjà tourné les vidéos je les ai tourné
là mon deuxième tournage sur youtube
space elles sont montées elles sont
planifiés en ligne tout est automatisé
vous aurez toujours votre vidéo tous les
jours moi pendant ce temps là donc je
lirai toujours vos commentaires je serai
moins présent sur la chaîne parce que
déjà les quinze premiers jours je serai
vraiment partis en vacances je pense
même pas avoir de connexion internet je
me faire un black out ça va faire du
bien et durant les quelques jours qui
resteront je serais rentré à paris là je
redeviendrai plus actif je continue
toujours de lire les commantaires j'y
répondrai un petit peu et surtout je
bosserai pour vous faire un retour
encore plus gros avec une chaîne encore
plus belles j'espère est qu'on se fasse
une belle dernière ligne droite jusqu'au
31 décembre
il ya déjà des choses qui sont en train
de se préparer mais je voulais préparer
bien je les faire bien dont une vidéo
avec poisson fécond j'en suis tellement
heureux qui va venir sur la chaîne une
haute avec mike byrd et d'autres que je
vous ai pas encore vous dire parce que
c'est pas sûr à 100% c'est pas calé mais
il ya du taf le job d'été le jeux des
énigmes il fonctionnera aussi comme ça
grâce à vous j'espère que ce sera un
rendez vous qui vous plaira j'espère que
vous partagerez les énigmes un petit peu
partout en tout cas je vous a à l'oeil
puisque je sais que tous les jours j'ai
ré lire vos commentaires je trouverai
toujours une solution de petites
connexions durant une heure au moins
pour ça passait de très très belles
vacances vous pouvez me souhaiter bonne
vacances avec un geste simple en
laissant un pouce en l'air merci d'être
là depuis le départ j'espère que tout ça
ça vous plaît que ça continuera de vous
plaire on se retrouve dans de vrais
quotidien fin août mais rester là
puisque la prochaine vidéo
c'est demain alors rendez vous demain à
17 heures ciao
oh